indirectly whether we know this or not
independent content creators that are
pushing against the envelope you know
you're part of the anti-establishment
crowd whether you know this or not we're
anti-establishment just because we're
not going the traditional route okay The
Establishment is who the journalists
that went to Columbia University and
they're reading the script and the
teleprompter tells them what to say and
they say it or somebody tells them in
their earpiece what to say to say it
it's somebody telling you in your ear
what to say we don't have that that's
not our model we don't have
teleprompters you know there's not a
teleprompter here for fresh to read what
he's doing you're letting your ribs